Welcome to Aera English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
In the States, we have a strange gesture we do with business cards.
When we get a business card from somebody, we look and we say,...
..."Oh! I know this person."
We smack the business card.
Of course, in Japan, this is unbelievable.
But when a foreigner does it to you, please don't be insulted.
Okay, today's topic...
Excuse me, do you mind if I cut in?
Please use it.
And next,...
...Sir, with all due respect.
With all due respect.
Sir, with all due respect.
Ma'am, with all due respect.
So, use this kind of English and you can cut in, in a business situation.
Let's practice.
Excuse me, do you mind if I cut in?
Please repeat.
Good!
And next,...
...Sir, with all due respect.
Please repeat.
Good!
Okay. And that's it for today.
And next week, there'll be more English to help you become the native maestro. Bye-bye.